nice hey there welcome back to the
homestead today i'm working on setting
up our off-grid
um garden irrigation system
this is a kit i got online on amazon
i'll put a link down below there's also
some extra parts that i got i'll also
put links for those if you watch the
tank video there's an irrigation ditch
up there and it feeds this tank
and my garden is not much lower than
this tank
so i don't have enough pressure with
gravity to give me my drip system
the pressure that it needs
so i got this well pump should do uh
we'll go over that a little bit later
and a solar charging system that will
hopefully give me the pressure that i
need to do a drip system and basically i
can just set it and forget it so
let's get started
nice
so we got the system all set up
we'll go through it real quickly uh
basically what we got here on the front
are we'll start with the structure this
was just an old uh crate that i came on
a project i was working on with a pallet
and uh sides
so i used one of the sides and i used
the pallet
seemed to work out pretty well
on that is two
100 watt solar panels for a total of 200
watts
just did some bracing here
just hold them up
and then those holes
are for uh the wires to come through
let's take a peek inside
uh the kit that i had gotten came with
the two solar panels
the charge controller and the solar
pump or and the well pump
along with assorted wires and all that
so we'll check out this the charger
basically what it does it takes the
solar panel
power and you plug it in here
that charges the battery
and also gives power to the load the
load in this case is going to be that
well pump
over here is a timer 12 volt timer
what that is doing is basically if if i
didn't have the timer the pump would
just run continuously
until the battery went dead or
we'll go over the setup on this real
quick
the white wire here this red and then
there's a black back there that is
feeding the timer it needs a little bit
of power to run
so i'm just robbing some power off the
load side to give that some juice
and then i'm taking the
positive side this red wire there
and feeding that to the timer
and then off that that white wire there
is running to the pump
and then the
negative
is just this and it just runs all the
way through to the pump so that is the
oh and then the battery is just a marine
grade battery a deep cell nothing too
special just the uh
i think i did group 24
so 70 to 85 amp hours
not really too sure how well it's going
to work but i think it should get us
where we want to be
at this time the sun is
a little cloudy out there
so there's not too much sun out but we
are doing 13.2 volts
the solar panel is charging the battery
and then the load is
operational but right now because the
timer
the pump is not running i just have it
on manually off let's go take a look at
the pump
okay so the way i ran it um through the
hole in the
tank lid
i have a rope the power wire and a half
inch
drip line hose i pulled the pump out so
that we can have a little look
it's got a
half inch barbed fitting back there oh i
put a
pipe clamp on there hose clamp i also
put a rope on there so i'm not tugging
on the
fitting there or also the power line
it's a pretty neat little setup
stainless steel they have so many
options of this
i went with this one because it is
a higher gpm
uh 3.2 gpm
and i wanted that for more
gallons per minute and also pressure
just a quick peek inside the tank
what i got it here
is a
float valve
basically
once the water comes up to a certain
level the float floats and turns off the
water
coming from the ditch up there
let's dunk this tank real quick
or the
pump
and we'll fire it up
so this has a auto
on and off
might be able to hear it
a little noisy there's some vibration in
there for sure
i did put a pressure gauge on here
so right now i'm going to turn on the
pressure gauge because now it's run into
the drip system and what happens here
is it has a lot of pressure
boom
so that gauge goes over
to 100 and as you've seen the needle
just went all the way around drip system
that i have here is set up for
10 psi and i wasn't thinking i would
even get as much psi as i'm getting now
but uh yeah this is actually a lot
better than i thought i'm actually gonna
have to get a regulator so yeah
let's go take a look at the drip system
so now i got the drip going and now it
starts to rain what i'm doing here is
i'm gonna do two two separate zones
there's nine beds i'm gonna separate
them into like four and five two lines
running this way
i haven't set these beds up yet
but i really wanted to see how this
thing worked so i did set up
these four beds here
the material that i'm using for the drip
system is known as drip tape
i guess they call it that because it
lays flat
and it has these
little slits right here
so this setup is designed to do
140 gallons
per hour per 100 foot
so these are 50 foot beds each bed has
two lines which means it has a hundred
foot of drip line
and then what happens when it gets
pressure which i think these are over
pressured for sure
it round it
rounds up like uh normal
uh irrigation tubing what i'm using for
the header is just
typical
black irrigation pipe
your standard drip irrigation
you know the stuff you get at the home
depot or whatever is capable of doing
much more pressure
i wasn't thinking i was going to have
this much pressure so that's why i went
with this
drip tape setup and you can see it
dripping there
i am going to put the camera away
because it is raining
but i do want to set this set up over
here and have you watch me so let me uh
see if the rain will pass
so
[Applause]
all righty well
that over there is a storm
got a few more uh plumbing fittings to
set up so i'm gonna put the camera away
before it gets soaking wet thanks for
watching we'll see on the next one